Starkoch Alfons Schuhbeck er gesteht
Steuerhinterziehung er hat seinen
Schweigen gebrochen jetzt gerade nachdem
man mit all diesen Stars und Promis
gekocht hat im Steuerprozess in München
ein Teil Geständnis von Alfons Schuhbeck
ja ich habe einiges falsch gemacht das
hat er gesagt ich habe mir meinen
Freunden meinen Bekannten und auch
meinen Verteidigern bis zuletzt etwas
vorgemacht weil ich nicht wahrhaben
wollte dass ich unternehmerisch
gescheitert bin das war also wirklich
ein Hoch emotionaler Moment da im
Gerichtssaal und wir wollen direkt zu
unserem Reporter Andreas Bachner schauen
der hat das ganze nämlich mitverfolgt
Andreas das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen
überraschend dass plötzlich dieses
Teilgeständnis kam warum gerade jetzt
ja das war auf jeden Fall eine
Kehrtwende mit der man zumindest so in
dieser Form nicht gerechnet hat aber
Alfons Schuhbeck hat das selber gesagt
er stand offensichtlich unter dem
Eindruck dieses ersten Prozesstages
letzte Woche als er noch geschwiegen hat
und er hat in seiner Erklärung auch
mitgeteilt in dem Moment als er diesen
Saal betreten hat wurde es ihm bewusst
ich habe was falsch gemacht und ich muss
mich jetzt dieser Verantwortung stellen
und das hat er gemacht er hat eine
siebenseitige Erklärung vorgelesen und
und hat darin erklärt im Teilgeständnis
abgelegt also es geht ja insgesamt und
viereinhalb Millionen Euro die er
entnommen haben soll in zwei Restaurants
über den Zeitraum von sieben Jahren und
in dem Restaurant Orlando am Platzl da
hat er zugegeben dass er immer wieder
die Rechnungen getürkt hat und auch
Gelder entnommen hat in den Südtiroler
Stuben wo es auch um über 2 Millionen
geht dafür konnte er aber keine
Erklärung finden aber er sagt er
übernimmt die Verantwortung er steht vor
den Trümmern seines Lebenswerks und er
hat eigentlich immer weiter gearbeitet
und hat sich dem nicht gestellt er sagte
auch dass er von morgen 7 Uhr in der
Früh bis nachts um eins eigentlich kann
man nicht gearbeitet hat und versucht
hat die Löcher zu stopfen und was er
auch erzählt hat was zum Beispiel die
Konten in der Karibik angeht da gab es
ja Spekulationen er sagt er habe nie ein
Leben im Luxus gefüllt geführt er habe
die Gelder für seine Familie verwendet
um seinen Kindern eine Ausbildung bieten
zu können und eben um unternehmerisch
die Löcher zu stopfen er hat das nie für
Luxus verwendet und es gäbe auch keine
Konten im Ausland im Gegenteil er hat
mitgeteilt dass er eben aus der Karibik
teilweise sogar Zahlung erhalten hat von
Investoren erst bei Steuerhinterziehung
am Ende wurscht ob man das Geld dann
dass man dann Steuern gespart hat für
die Ausbildung der Kinder benutzt hat
natürlich natürlich waren Arbeitstier
das wussten wir alle von Alfons
Schuhbeck du hast ihn jetzt gesehen
diese festtagelang an die dort im
Gerichtssaal war das jetzt eine
taktische Finesse von ihm dass er
gefühlt hat ich steht da im Prozess mit
dem Rücken zur Wand ich kann eigentlich
nur noch die Karten auf den Tisch legen
oder war das ein ganz menschlicher
Moment dass er gespürt hat ich muss hier
irgendwie doch als ehrliche Haut raus
ich glaube das ist eine Mischung aus
beiden war er hat er gesagt er hat sich
auch seinen Verteidigern erst nach
diesem ersten Prozess Tag offenbart ich
denke dass er wirklich da erst gemerkt
hat wo ich stehe wirklich mit dem mit
dem mit dem Rücken zur Wand und ich muss
jetzt was machen ich glaube dass er
wirklich bis zum letzten Moment gedacht
hat er kann das noch irgendwie gerade
biegen aber es war auch ein sehr
menschlicher ein Hoch emotionaler Moment
und und er hat eigentlich auch ein
bisschen eine Show wie bei einer
Kochsendung abgezogen und man hat
gemerkt was er für ein Mensch ist er hat
immer wieder für Launen und für Lacher
gesorgt im Saal wo es eigentlich darum
geht ob er jetzt ins Gefängnis muss oder
nicht hat von seinen Aufstieg erzählt
hat erzählt wir in Paris gekocht hat wie
ein London gekocht hat wie er Sean
Connery begegnet ist wir langsam sein
Imperium aufgebaut hat und ich glaube
dass er bis zuletzt gehofft hat dass er
das irgendwie noch retten kann und
wirklich erst an diesem ersten
Verhandlungstag gemerkt hat das wird
nicht mehr
hat dieses Teilgeständnis denn jetzt
irgendeine Auswirkung auf ein mögliches
Strafmaß was droht denn Schuhbeck jetzt
im schlimmsten Fall also ist droht ihm
von vornherein nach einem Urteil des BGH
vor zehn Jahren
ab einer Summe von einer Million Euro
hinterzogenen Steuern und bei Schuhbeck
sind es 2,3 Millionen Euro um die es
hier geht droht automatisch eine
Haftstrafe ohne Bewerbung also das droht
ihm sowieso aber natürlich wenn er jetzt
so früh mit einem Geständnis kommt es
wird sich strafmildernd auswirken und
jetzt kommt es darauf an was ihm
nachgewiesen werden kann aber er hat
eben gesagt er er übernimmt die
Verantwortung für alles was da in der
Anklage steht und das sind eben 2,3
Millionen Euro an hinterzogenen Steuern
und das würde in dem Fall auch eine
Haftstrafe für ihn bedeuten wie hoch die
ausfallen wird das können wir jetzt noch
nicht sagen aber dieses Geständnis oder
dieses frühe Teilgeständnis wird sich
definitiv strafmildern für ihn auswirken
was für ein Auftritt dort heute vor
Gericht von Alfons Schuhbeck dem Star
Koch überraschendes Teilgeständnis von
ihm heute in diesem
steuerhinterziehungsprozess und mit
dabei immer unser Bild Reporter an die
Bachner danke dir
[Musik]